so we're going to begin our last session
but one this session is a kind of
futurology session our speakers are dr.
Pym ski of the higher School of Business
in novice saunch and Poland which is the
best private polish university today and
the Honorable board esta de su the
former foreign minister of ukraine and
perhaps i will begin by introducing both
of them and then we'll will allow them
to do what they came to do for estado
sukh was actually is a very experienced
diplomat and a member of the foreign
policy community in ukraine he received
his degree from Kiev State University
went to work for the foreign ministry
and worked his way up the ladder so to
speak between 1992 and 1994 mr. Thomas
ook was deputy foreign minister of
ukraine in 1998 in april he became
foreign minister he was foreign minister
for two and a half years I'm delighted
to say that mr. Tata suit was a regular
visitor here at Columbia University and
of course in the United States many many
times in the 1990s and probably before
that he is the leader of group it was
elected to the Gulf narada on the
nationalists and today he's going to
tell us about where he thinks ukraine is
and where ukraine is going in the next
few years his colleague sitting just
immediately to his left is dr. pol names
key dr. Minsky has a PhD in chemistry he
was a founding member of core in the
1970s was of course harassed by police
as were all members of
at that time he was active in the Polish
scouting movement and therefore very
interested in what young people do
between nineteen seventy-seven and
nineteen eighty he Co organized and led
an underground journal called gross he
was its editor and printer which gave
him a lot of experience in moving people
and things around so that authorities
don't know what's going on and that came
in very handy when he became the head of
the state protection agency in 1993
under the the government of mr. Yan
Olszewski mr. nine ski found himself
before that here in the United States
for a few years like so many poles who
were visiting the United States
temporarily in 1981 and found their
stays prolonged by the immense goodness
and goodwill of generally I was else ki
who declared martial law and forced them
to stay here for a time in any case in
the later 1990s in 1997 when the
government of Prime Minister guzik was
organized mr. dymski was adviser on
national security to the Prime Minister
and was involved in the delicate and at
least partially successful negotiations
over bringing Norwegian gas to Poland
something that the government of mr.
Miller who now is about to resign
initially turned down and now again is
very interested in at present and for
the last few years dr. Minsky has been
associated with the higher School of
Business in navasota and he is the
co-creator of the international
relations department and also the soon
to be a political science department at
that institution where he is a vice dean
I think we would begin with mr. Todd a
suit if you like
ah if you can stop this is double prime
democratically instructor thank you very
much dr. McGill for presenting for your
kind words ladies and gentlemen when I
received this proposal to visit this
conference I had no hesitations from the
very beginning because for me the
Ukrainian polish relationship where r
and will be the most important out the
world relationship Ukraine has with the
neighbors and I would like to
congratulate the Columbia University for
this initiative to conduct this
conference at these days especially
taking into account that in three days
in Kiev there will be official opening
of the year of Poland in Ukraine that is
next Tuesday March 2920 30s when
president quest near ski and president
kuchma would officially inaugurate the
year of Poland in Ukraine and the next
year will be a year of Ukraine in Poland
certainly I think that both events would
contribute considerably into the change
of perceptions including the negative
ones in both societies suggest being
suggested to speak on the Ukrainian
polish relationship and the future you
know this is not an easy task so for
this purpose I would like to to say a
few words
what background this future is being
formed from my point of view when we are
speaking about this two countries which
are of great interest to all you present
here and beyond this whole we are
speaking about two largest Central and
Eastern European countries we are
speaking about the countries which are
both strategic